Going to tell you a story from the
Soviet Union,
it's Solzhenitsyn.
He introduces it with the whole from the
Russian poet laureate cost.
So sympathizer with cohesion,
construction,
grit and repression.
Wring the neck of this gang.
Right?
That's nice.
Pole socialists and wonderful.
Who was the gay?
That's the question.
As I said,
he has to make 66 million people died
between 1970 and 1950.
Nine.
Socialists are also estimated that
substantially larger number of in
Communist China.
No one really knows the staff's on map.
Now.
This is a debatable statistic as social
next one.
Points out spoke business from the Gulag
archipelago as soon as the official
statistics are released to revise their
estimates.
This includes,
for example,
separate millions billion hasn't pushed
into the Tundra forced relocation at
nearly $26 million trainings.
We've famines in 1930.
Second preview story.
So this is the situation.
So I'll tell you a little bit about his
life story.
It was a three volume.
The second volume of which you will read
a story about blue light system of
forced labor camps set up in the Soviet
Union.
Soon after Lennon died.
In fact,
yes,
some of them were set up before he died
and upon which the Soviet economy brand
for much of what constituted it's nets
and started his travels through the
gulag originally as a Russian front line
soldier storing sense thrown into a
German prisoner of war camp and when he
was repatriated to the Soviet Union
styling through later in a concentration
camp and the reason why is as he did
with all of the return Russian prisoners
of war who were treated by the week
terribly in the German prisoners of war
camps because Stalin refused to sign the
Geneva Convention on the treatment of
prisoners.
So not only were they in prisoners of
war camps,
which was miserable enough that they
were starved to the degree that the
other ally prisoners used to give them
food.
They didn't have much food themselves.
So he was a front line soldier.
Then he got thrown into German prisoner
of war camp and then when he finally
returned to Russia,
tell him through when it comes to
training camp.
And the reason for that was that the
Russians who were in German prisoners of
war camp had been contaminated by their
exposure to western ideas and that was
his rationale.
So anyways,
that he's spent a decade and a half of
their boats in concentration camps,
but when he got out and developed
stomach cancer.
So that's a brief summary of some of the
highlights of his life.
Okay.
In this scene,
he's being transported from one camp to
another rail car and it's been roughly
outfitted for transporting human beings.
He's sitting with a friend that he calls
panic.
I'm just going to read you this story.
My friend Pat and I are lying on the
Middle Shelf of a stall up into cattle
cars.
Basically they're refitted for fema
transport and have set ourselves up
constantly talk to our assault herring
in her pocket.
So we don't need water.
I can go to sleep,
but at some station or other,
they shoved into our compartment.
A Marxist scholar.
We can tell this from his guilty and
spectacles.
He doesn't hide the fact.
So He's been arrested.
He's a devout communist,
been arrested by the Columbias.
He doesn't hide the fact.
He's a former professor of the communist
academy.
We have down in the square,
cut out from his very first words.
We see that comedians impenetrable.
We have been serving time for a very
long time and have a long time lift
serve and we value of Mary joke.
We'd been fun.
There's ample space left in the
compartment,
so we exchanged places with someone in
crown.
Ian.
Hello?
Hello.
You know,
too crowded.
No,
it's all right.
Have you been in the jug a long time?
Long enough?
Are you past the halfway mark?
Just look over there.
How poverty stricken or villages are?
Straw thatch,
crooked hugs.
That's an inheritance Harrington's from
the czarist regime.
What we've already had 30 Soviet years.
That's an insignificant period.
Historically.
It's terrible that the collective
farmers are starving at older.
Just ask any collective farmer in our
compartment,
put everyone in jail is the bitter and
prejudice,
but I've seen collective farms myself.
That means they were on characteristic.
The goatee had never been in any way
simpler.
Just ask the old folks desire.
They were well Fed,
well upload,
and they used to have many holidays.
I'm not even going to ask.
It's a subjective trait of human memory
to praise everything past the cow that
died is the one that gave twice the
milk.
Sometimes even say,
and our people don't like qualities.
They like to work.
Why is there a shortage of brand in many
cities when right before the war,
for example,
not true before the war,
everything.
In fact,
he worked at.
Listen at that time in all the cities on
the pool guy,
there were accused of thousands of
people,
a local failure in supply.
More likely your memory's failing you,
but there is a shortage now.
Old Wives Tales,
we hear it from seven to 8 billion
bushels of grain.
The grain is rotten,
not so.
We've been very successful in developing
new species and so forth.
He's in her term of speaks in the
language which requires no effort of the
mining and arguing with him is like
walking through a desert.
It's about people like that,
but they say he made the rounds of all
the blocks,
miss and came home unsure when they
write in their obituaries perished
tragically during the period of the
stout on this cult,
it should be corrected to read.
Parish comically had worked out
differently.
We would have never learned what a dry,
insignificant little man he really was.
We would have respectfully made his name
in the newspaper.
We would have.
He would have become a people's
commissar or even venture to represent
all of Russia abroad.
To argue with him was useless.
It was much more interested in playing
with it.
Not a chess,
but at the game really is such a game.
It's very simple game play off to him a
couple of times or so.
Use some of his own pet words and
phrases like that phrase growing
accustomed to find all around who were
in a.
he's become weary of star like it
doesn't mind to tell his stories because
all of them will be twisted and thrown
right back into space,
but if he takes you for one of his own,
he will quite disclose to you.
What are you seeing that the station
people are passing by?
Talking,
laughing.
Life goes on.
The party is providing leadership.
People are being moved from job to job.
You and I are languishing in prison.
There are only a handful of us and we
must write and write petitions,
begging a review of our cases being a
part or he will tell you something
interesting in the Communist Academy,
they just started to devour one cobra.
We decided he wasn't going to Jannie
with one of our own.
Somehow they could manage it.
There are no errors and his assets and
his biography was clean and all of a
sudden going through the archives,
what I find,
they ran across an old brochure written
by his comrade in which Bladimir Lennon
himself.
He held in his hands and in the margin
of which he had written in his own
handwriting.
The notation as an economist is shit,
well now you understand our.
Anything smiled eventually,
but after that it's no trouble at all to
make short work of that month we foster
he was expelled from the academy in
deprived to the scholar,
a communist professor.
This exchange,
he doesn't think.
It doesn't have to think because he has
an ideological system worked out.
He won't admit any evidence whatsoever
exists to suggest some of these
presuppositions are wrong for every bit
of evidence that exists.
There is a counter argument that
justifies it or excuse it or makes it
disappear in some way.
That's the first part.
The second part of the story is that
being like this,
he's also extraordinarily clannish in
this sense.
Can you tell us a brief story about
being in the academy where everyone
shares that you Ologie and finding
outside so that you can essentially
destroy their specific reasons why the
two halves of that narrative who stuck
together because the first attitude
leads an exorbitant to the second
attitude to say the adoption of
authoritarian ideology,
which is basically the presumption of
innocence.
If your Nav along,
you think that what you think is the
right thing thing,
there isn't anything else that needs to
be thought.
It's you that has the answer.
Now,
you might go to you.
You might think that it's your leader or
the ideology in and of itself,
but what it is you're the one that's in
possession of the truth and every fact
that might exist to dispute that is
eliminated.
The problem with the fact is that
sometimes they come in and body forms,
which is the same.
We tend to think of ideas as
disembodied,
abstracted entities of truth of the
matter is that ideas are representations
of human patterns of action and
sometimes the enemy idea is actually the
enemy and there's very little difference
from the practical perspective between
repressing thoughts that are
uncomfortable and repressing.
People whose viewpoints or even styles
of existence are equal.